Hey guys, my name's Lewis, I'm 27 years old and I'm from Bavaria, Germany.
大家好，我叫刘易斯，今年 27 岁，来自德国巴伐利亚。
I'm a very sensitive person.
我是一个非常敏感的人。
I dream too big and I feel too much and growing up it's been so easy to become emotionally closed off.
我的梦想太大，感觉太多，在成长过程中，我很容易在情感上变得封闭。
I often catch myself drifting into this kind of an numbness where I just feel I don't belong but Ted gave and still gives me the strength to keep fighting for that vulnerable part of myself even when it so often feels like a fight for a lost cause.
我经常发现自己陷入了这种麻木状态，我只是觉得自己不属于这里，但泰德给了我力量，并且仍然给了我继续为自己脆弱的部分而战的力量，即使这常常感觉像是在为失败的事业而战。
I'll stay out here on this cold roof for a little longer.
我会在这个冰冷的屋顶上再呆一会儿。
And I cannot thank you guys enough for that.
对此我非常感谢你们。
I'm alone, I'll be soon in New York City when I see you.
我孤身一人，见到你时我很快就会到纽约。
Please permit me to tell you everything, York City.
请允许我告诉你一切，约克市。
Well, hello and welcome to another episode of How We Made Your Mother.
好吧，大家好，欢迎收看《我们如何创造了你的母亲》的另一集。
I'm Josh Radner.
我是乔什·拉德纳。
I played Ted Mosby on How I Met Your Mother.
我在《老爸老妈的浪漫史》中扮演泰德·莫斯比。
every single episode from 2005 to 2013.
2005年到2013年的每一集。
Is that right?
是这样吗？
Yeah.
是的。
No, 13, 13.
不，13，13。
Damn it.
该死的。
13, yeah.
13，是的。
And I am joined.
我也加入了。
14, sorry, Josh.
14，对不起，乔什。
It is definitely 14.
肯定是14了。
It was nine years.
已经九年了。
Here we go.
开始了。
Good start.
好的开始。
The great start.
伟大的开始。
Hi, Craig Thomas.
嗨，克雷格·托马斯。
I'm joined by Craig Thomas.
克雷格·托马斯也加入了我的行列。
He co-created the show with Carter Bass.
他与卡特·巴斯共同创作了该节目。
Hi, Craig.
嗨，克雷格。
I'm disoriented but happy to be here.
我迷失了方向，但很高兴来到这里。
I don't know what year it is.
我不知道现在是哪一年。
We are joined today by a ray of sunshine is illuminating this riverside studio space with us today.
今天，一缕阳光照亮了我们这个河畔的工作室空间。
We have the very wonderful, endlessly entertaining and fun and delightful Ashley Williams who played Victoria in 16 episodes.
我们有非常精彩、无穷无尽的娱乐性、有趣和令人愉快的阿什利·威廉姆斯（Ashley Williams），她在 16 集中扮演了维多利亚。
Is that right?
是这样吗？
I think that's correct.
我认为这是正确的。
We can't count, but don't take our word for it.
我们无法计算，但也不要相信我们的话。
We don't even know how many seasons we did.
我们甚至不知道我们经历了多少个赛季。
This is not, we're not nailing the math this, I'm high, Ashley, hi, welcome.
这不是，我们没有搞清楚数学，我很高兴，阿什利，嗨，欢迎。
Hi, Josh.
嗨，乔什。
Hi, Craig, I'm so excited to be here.
嗨，克雷格，我很高兴来到这里。
Thank you so much for having me.
非常感谢你邀请我。
I love the podcast.
我喜欢播客。
Oh, thanks.
哦，谢谢。
Yeah, it's so cool to be now on a podcast that I'm genuinely a fan of.
是的，现在能加入我真正喜欢的播客真是太酷了。
I'm really enjoying listening to the show.
我真的很喜欢听这个节目。
So make us a quick commercial.
所以让我们做一个快速的广告。
What do you love about our podcast?
您喜欢我们的播客的哪些方面？
And by the way, stealth FU to every other podcast you've ever been on.
顺便说一句，请悄悄告诉您曾经收听过的所有其他播客。
You are the best.
你是最棒的。
Ashley, she is the best of the best.
阿什莉，她是最好的。
The day is better when you see Ashley when you experience just being anywhere near her, even on a computer screen.
当你看到阿什莉时，只要你感觉就在她身边，即使是在电脑屏幕上，你的日子就会更好。
Thank you for being Victoria and thank you for being here.
感谢你成为维多利亚，感谢你来到这里。
We love you very much.
我们非常爱你。
I love you guys.
我爱你们。
I'm so happy it was a miraculous job back in the day and the dividends continue.
我很高兴这在当时是一项奇迹般的工作，而且红利还在继续。
Actually, how do you, like, I know that was a Ted-centered testimonial from our friend in Bavaria, but what's that like when you hear these testimonials about what the show means to people and how invested they continue to be after so many years?
事实上，你怎么知道这是我们在巴伐利亚的朋友以泰德为中心的感言，但是当你听到这些关于这部剧对人们意味着什么以及他们在这么多年之后继续投入的感言时，感觉怎么样？
You know what's so funny is like, you guys have said this before, and I know just from talking to you personally, like, at the time, you know, we were, Josh, like, we were newer actors in the industry, and I was like, like, oh my gosh, how did you get a pilot, Josh?
你知道什么是那么有趣的是，你们以前说过这个，我只是通过与你们私下交谈就知道了，就像，当时，我们是，乔什，就像，我们是这个行业的新演员，我当时想，天哪，你是怎么找到飞行员的，乔什？
Like, how did you, you know what I mean?
就像，你怎么知道我的意思？
Like, that was the majority of our initial conversations when we first got to know each other was like, I can't believe you're on this show, I can't believe it's picked up for like 12.
就像，当我们第一次认识彼此时，我们最初的对话主要是这样的，我不敢相信你会出现在这个节目中，我不敢相信它的播出时间是 12 点左右。
Well, do you remember, I don't know if you remember where I met you, we talked about this, but I don't think you'll remember.
好吧，你还记得吗，我不知道你是否还记得我在哪里遇见你的，我们讨论过这个，但我想你不会记得了。
I went to a taping of Good Morning Miami because I was friends with Mark Foyerstein.
我去看了《早安迈阿密》的录音，因为我是马克·福耶斯坦的朋友。
And I met you kind of briefly, But that's how I knew you, because you were on that show.
我认识你的时间很短，但这就是我认识你的方式，因为你参加了那个节目。
You remember that show.
你还记得那个节目。
That's fascinating.
这很有趣。
I do remember that show, but what was really interesting about that show, that was my first TV job out of college.
我确实记得那个节目，但那个节目真正有趣的是，那是我大学毕业后的第一份电视工作。
I had only done a bunch of theater.
我只演过一些戏剧。
And Mark Feuerstein is one of the golden humans in my life.
马克·福尔斯坦是我生命中的黄金人物之一。
Shout out to Mark, yes.
向马克大喊，是的。
Shout out to Mark.
向马克大喊。
And also it was an education in, You know, what I think is really common in sitcom culture, which is it's an incredibly competitive amongst the writers to make sure that people's jokes are getting in and tape night can go badly and tape night can go well and it's stressful and the ratings are up and down.
这也是一种教育，你知道，我认为在情景喜剧文化中非常普遍，那就是编剧之间的竞争非常激烈，以确保人们的笑话能够进入，磁带之夜可能会很糟糕，也可能会进展顺利，压力很大，收视率上下波动。
It's not, you know, I've now done a ton of different mediums in television and the multi-cam medium had been incredibly stressful medium for me to to be thrown into right out of school.
你知道，我现在已经在电视领域做过很多不同的媒体，而多机位媒体对我来说是一个压力极大的媒体，让我在离开学校后就被扔进了这个媒体。
So it's so interesting that you came to a tape of Good Morning Miami because they were incredibly stressful times for me.
所以很有趣的是，你看到了《早安迈阿密》的磁带，因为那段时间对我来说压力很大。
And it's part of how when I first started on the show, I first got the job.
这也是我刚开始参加这个节目时，第一次得到这份工作的一部分。
And I mean, I remember the audition so well, I remember booking it.
我的意思是，我非常清楚地记得试镜，我记得预订了它。
On how I met your mother or Good Morning Miami?
关于我如何认识你母亲或早安迈阿密？
No, on how I met your mother.
不，关于我是如何认识你母亲的。
I remember it so well.
我记得很清楚。
And I remember coming in and being absolutely terrified of a multi-cam format.
我记得刚进来时我对多机位格式感到非常恐惧。
And I remember day one, you all setting the tone, which was this kind, all-inclusive, like first thing out of the gate is we finished the table read and we all went straight to breakfast.
我记得第一天，你们都定下了基调，这是一种包罗万象的基调，就像走出大门的第一件事就是我们读完表格，然后我们都直接去吃早餐。
And it was all under the, you know, guidance of Pam Fryman.
这一切都是在帕姆·弗莱曼 (Pam ​​Fryman) 的指导下进行的。
Like it was a very, it was a very like, you're safe here, everything's okay, kind of vibe, which I definitely did not trust.
就像是一种非常非常喜欢的感觉，你在这里很安全，一切都很好，有种氛围，但我绝对不相信这种感觉。
I was like, sure, sure, we'll see what happens on tape night.
我当时想，当然，当然，我们会看看磁带之夜会发生什么。
You know, it was like my mentality was like, well, we'll see.
你知道，我的心态就像是，好吧，我们拭目以待。
It's a tape three days, which, yeah, you might not have known coming in, yeah.
这是一盘三天的磁带，是的，你可能不知道它进来了，是的。
I didn't.
我没有。
And I also, then was like, as soon as you were like, no, no, no, it's different around here.
然后我也说，一旦你说，不，不，不，这里不一样。
I was like, well, I'm definitely gonna get fired after the network run through.
我当时想，好吧，网络运行完毕后我肯定会被解雇。
Did you really feel that?
你真的有这样的感觉吗？
Oh, yeah, big time.
哦，是的，很重要。
Because that was the culture I came from on Good Morning Miami.
因为这就是我在《早安迈阿密》中来自的文化。
People were replaced left and right after, you know, table reads after run through is all that.
你知道，在运行完之后读表就可以了，人员被左右替换。
So in so many ways, the show was this healing salve for my soul, you know, my multi-camera wounds, yeah.
所以从很多方面来说，这部剧都是我灵魂的治愈药膏，你知道，我的多镜头伤口，是的。
And that was a good morning, Miami was like a live studio audience, like high pressure.
那是一个美好的早晨，迈阿密就像现场演播室的观众一样，压力很大。
Like we have a big, that changes the vibe so much, I think.
我认为，就像我们有一个大的一样，这极大地改变了氛围。
I do have a very strong memory, actually, of watching James Burroughs, who was directing and watching him not watch the monitors, but snap his fingers.
事实上，我确实对观看詹姆斯·巴勒斯（James Burroughs）有一个非常强烈的记忆，他是导演，看着他不看监视器，而是打响指。
Like he's like, he was like a band leader.
就像他一样，他就像一个乐队指挥。
He was like pacing the show.
他就像是在为演出节奏。
Which was such a great education in comedy because he taught me about the musicality of serving up the joke and all of that, which I truly like didn't, from theater, it was a little bit more organic, you know?
这是一次很棒的喜剧教育，因为他教会了我讲笑话的音乐性，而我真正喜欢的所有这些，在戏剧中却没有，它更加有机，你知道吗？
But this was, serve it and serve it hard and land your jokes.
但这是，服务它，努力服务它，然后开你的玩笑。
And if you don't, somebody's gonna come talk to you and be like, this is not working.
如果你不这样做，就会有人过来跟你说，这行不通。
Yeah, but you know, it's an interesting thing.
是的，但你知道，这是一件有趣的事情。
Like I always, maybe you share this.
像往常一样，也许你会分享这个。
I always love working with older actors because they have a level of like relaxation and not giving a shit that is so enviable when you're younger, you're like, how do you get to that place where you're just like so relaxed, the jokes, you're not even, you don't look like you're trying, you look like you're just thinking about your sandwich, you're gonna have for lunch and it's endlessly watchable and captivating.
我总是喜欢和年长的演员一起工作，因为他们有一种放松的感觉，一点也不在意，这在你年轻的时候是非常令人羡慕的，你会想，你是如何到达那个你如此放松的地方的，笑话，你不均匀，你看起来不像你在尝试，你看起来只是在想你的三明治，你要吃午饭，它是无限观看和迷人的。
There's something about being a new actor and especially, you know, I think because we We both went to theater school.
作为一名新演员，尤其是，你知道，我想是因为我们都上过戏剧学校。
You went to Carnegie.
你去了卡内基。
No, you went to BU, right?
不，你去了BU，对吗？
I went to BU.
我去了BU。
My husband went to Carnegie Mellon, yeah.
是的，我丈夫去了卡内基梅隆大学。
And I went to NYU, and I felt like I was trained for theater jobs.
我去了纽约大学，我觉得我接受了剧院工作的培训。
I knew how to get a script, I knew how to do the rehearsal, I knew how to be in the theater.
我知道如何拿到剧本，我知道如何排练，我知道如何进入剧院。
They do not teach you how to be on a set of a TV show, of a movie.
他们不会教你如何参加电视节目或电影的拍摄。
You are really thrown in a deep end.
你真的陷入了深渊。
I remember Andre Brouwer came and talked to us, and he's like, do you know what the tape on the floor means?
我记得安德烈·布劳威尔过来和我们说话，他说，你知道地板上的胶带意味着什么吗？
such a language of a set that you have to figure out.
这种语言是你必须弄清楚的。
And if you're good enough to get cast or you're lucky enough to get cast and often both, you are really thrown into the, you're just like tossed off the boat and you're like, you better learn how to swim, you know?
如果你足够优秀，或者你足够幸运，而且经常两者兼而有之，那么你真的会被扔进，你就像被从船上扔下来，你会想，你最好学会如何游泳，知道吗？
But you have to really, you have to really pay attention.
但你必须真正地、你必须真正地注意。
Yeah, I also think like for those of us trained in theater, which truly I thought I was going to be doing regional theater in Ashland, Oregon for the rest of like, I, my agent was like, come for pilot season.
是的，我也认为对于我们这些受过戏剧训练的人来说，我确实认为我会在俄勒冈州阿什兰的地区剧院度过余下的时间，就像我，我的经纪人一样，来参加试播季。
And I was like, it's not going to go well.
我当时想，事情不会顺利。
And suddenly I'm on after friends and before Seinfeld in a sitcom and it's theater but it's taped and I was I still I'm still confused playing for where's the you know how big do I go the the camera's right here but the audience is over here can they hear me like what you know like and working out levels is so much of what you're trying to figure out in a multi-cam setting that was my issue was like how a bit, how broad, how subtle, though they literally can't even hear me, you know, as opposed to in a single cam format, it's a little bit more sort of organic, and you can try it again, and you know, my experience of going to multi cam tapings, and I've been to a bunch in my life.
突然间，我在一部情景喜剧中，在《宋飞正传》之前，在《朋友们》之后，它是剧院，但它是录音的，我仍然很困惑，在哪里玩，你知道我要开多大，摄像机就在这里，但观众在这里，他们能像你知道的那样听到我的声音吗？在多机位环境中，你要弄清楚的就是如何确定级别，这就是我的问题，就像是多一点、多广泛、多微妙，尽管他们实际上不能甚至听我说，你知道，与单机位格式相比，它更加有机，你可以再试一次，你知道，我进行多机位录音的经历，我一生中去过很多次。
It's funny because I was on this famous multi cam show, but I haven't even been to that many multi cam traditional tapings.
这很有趣，因为我参加了这个著名的多机位表演，但我什至没有去过那么多多机位传统录音。
But my experience was always, this is hilarious, right?
但我的经验总是，这很搞笑，对吧？
It's like really fun.
这真的很有趣。
It's really the writer's throw in changes and the audience gets excited.
这确实是编剧的改变，观众很兴奋。
They're pumping the audience full of candy sugar to keep them, you know, alert for three and a half hours.
他们给观众灌满了糖，让他们在三个半小时内保持警惕。
And when I would watch the same episode on the air, I'd be like, they seem cranked up.
当我在广播中观看同一集时，我会想，他们似乎很兴奋。
They seem amped up in a way that they didn't quite seem.
他们似乎以一种看似不那么兴奋的方式兴奋起来。
And I always thought there was something about us, you know, we've talked about this, we talked about this with Kobe, like you, the crew would laugh once, maybe chuckle on the second, you know, take, but you were not playing for laughs on how I met your mother.
我一直认为我们身上有一些东西，你知道，我们讨论过这个，我们和科比讨论过这个，就像你一样，工作人员会笑一次，也许第二次会笑，你知道，但你不是为了笑我如何遇见你的母亲。
You knew you had to know where the laughs were, but you had to trust that the material was funny enough that in the absence of the immediate feedback, you would still be able to find your way.
你知道你必须知道笑点在哪里，但你必须相信这些材料足够有趣，以至于在没有立即反馈的情况下，你仍然能够找到自己的方式。
The jokes would make sense.
这些笑话是有道理的。
The plot would make sense.
情节是有道理的。
There was just something about, I think it kept us a little more honest not to have that audience like, and I agree with you, like, who am I playing for?
只是有一些事情，我认为这让我们更加诚实，不让观众喜欢，我同意你的观点，比如，我在为谁打球？
Like, I sometimes feel like actors get jacked up and they play for the audience, but you've really got to play for the camera.
就像，我有时觉得演员被抬高了，他们为观众表演，但你真的必须为镜头表演。
And I wrote you this little day to send you in New York City will be right back and now back to the show.
我今天写信给你，是为了让你在纽约马上回来，现在就回到演出现场。
Yeah.
是的。
And did you actually like coming into him?
你真的喜欢进入他吗？
Once you realized what it was, it was like this little three day movie shoot and you didn't have to play to the back row of the bleachers.
一旦你意识到这是什么，这就像三天的小电影拍摄，你不必在看台的后排表演。
Did that change the game of what you did?
这是否改变了你所做的事情？
Like I'm, for example, I didn't, we'll just say this because we haven't said this yet.
就像我一样，例如，我没有，我们会这么说，因为我们还没有这么说过。
We're going to talk about kind of Victoria's whole arc on the show with Ashley today and also touch a little bit on zip, zip, zip, because that's kind of ostensibly the episode we're talking about.
今天我们要和阿什利一起讨论维多利亚在节目中的整个弧线，并且还会触及一点拉链，拉链，拉链，因为表面上这就是我们正在谈论的剧集。
We're kind of going to mix it all together.
我们会把它们混合在一起。
If everybody, there may be a couple of spoilers, you might jump ahead and in Victoria's arc, so just know that comma audience.
如果大家都知道，可能会有一些剧透，你可能会跳到维多利亚的弧线上，所以只要知道逗号观众就可以了。
But back to Ashley, okay, so I'm thinking of like in drum roll, please, just to jump into that one, the smallness of your and Josh's scenes together, they're very intimate.
但回到阿什利，好吧，所以我想像鼓乐一样，请跳入其中，你和乔什在一起的场景很小，他们非常亲密。
the two of you on that piano bench and Ted is playing piano and you guys are really connecting and really firting but it's small and intimate and if that was in front of a live studio audience there would be a temptation to play it a totally different way and something about your guy's connectivity in that scene and many other scenes like it in that episode and others like is that kind of impossible to do in that sort of like amped upsetting of the live studio audience and did you feel that difference.
你们两个坐在钢琴凳上，泰德正在弹钢琴，你们真的很亲密，很亲密，但它又小又亲密，如果这是在现场演播室观众面前，就会有一种诱惑，以完全不同的方式演奏它，而你的家伙在那个场景中的连通性以及该集和其他类似场景中的许多其他场景，在那种让现场演播室观众感到不安的情况下是不可能做到的，你感受到这种差异了吗？
So being on him.
所以就靠在他身上了。
So here's where I bring in our my only audience member on how I met your mother was Pam.
所以在这里，我请来了唯一的观众，讲述我是如何认识你母亲的，那就是帕姆。
It was I was just just doing the play for her.
我只是在为她演戏而已。
And she was very strict about like, like, whoa, whoa, whoa.
她对像，像，哇，哇，哇非常严格。
You know, like, don't don't wreak of desperation here, Ashley, you know, and it really helped me to contain, you know, and keep it really real and grounded.
你知道，就像，不要在这里陷入绝望，阿什利，你知道，这确实帮助我控制，你知道，并保持它的真实和脚踏实地。
That, for me, that was all her.
对我来说，这就是她的全部。
And I had weirdly, I think she was doing- That's not correct.
奇怪的是，我认为她正在做——那是不正确的。
You're a Pam Fryman, by the way.
顺便说一句，你是帕姆·弗莱曼。
Pam Fryman.
帕姆·弗莱曼。
Yeah.
是的。
I do remember- She's magic.
我确实记得——她很神奇。
She's magic.
她很神奇。
But she was doing another show when I was doing Good Morning, Miami, and I kept seeing her and being like, I'm scared.
但当我在做《早安，迈阿密》时，她正在做另一场演出，我一直看到她，然后感觉，我很害怕。
This is hard.
这很难。
She was sort of counseled me in the parking lot, you know, about being on this- on this multi-cam that I was on and so having her there and then I trusted her like implicitly and she she really grounded me so for me it was all about her what about you Josh did you I mean well I'm thinking back to drumroll please and I just remember it felt like a film like it felt like a film and I know it was kind of structured to be I mean it was a little bit it's the traditional non-linear kind of fractured narrative.
她在停车场里给我提供了一些建议，你知道，关于参加这个节目——在我参加的这个多镜头上，所以有她在场，然后我含蓄地信任她，她真的让我接地气，所以对我来说，这一切都是关于她的，你呢乔什，你我的意思是，我正在回想鼓乐，请，我只记得它感觉就像一部电影，就像一部电影一样，我知道它的结构是我的意思是它有点像传统的非线性类型支离破碎的叙事。
But at the same time, if you bookend all our scenes together, it had that kind of Richard Link letter before sunrise, before sunset quality of like two people discovering each other and the audience getting to watch you discover them.
但与此同时，如果你把我们所有的场景都记录在一起，它就会有那种日出前、日落前理查德·林克的信，就像两个人发现彼此，观众看着你发现他们。
I do remember, I love that last scene with us where I come in and my bow ties on tide and it just looks like the wedding's already over.
我确实记得，我喜欢我们在一起的最后一幕，我进来时，我的领结很潮，看起来婚礼已经结束了。
You know, we've just been wandering through ballrooms and stuff for so long.
你知道，我们已经在舞厅之类的地方闲逛了这么久。
And that, you know, where you kind of have me close my eyes and, you know, Victoria has to close his eyes and you're gone, you're like poof gone.
你知道，你让我闭上眼睛，你知道，维多利亚必须闭上眼睛，你就消失了，你就像噗的一声消失了。
I remember our almost kiss and our, I don't know, it felt incredibly intimate.
我记得我们几乎接吻了，我们的，我不知道，感觉非常亲密。
It felt like this is not an average sitcom.
感觉这不是一部普通的情景喜剧。
Like if it had this elevated cinematic quality to it, which I remember, I felt like by that point we were really dropped into the tone of the episode.
就像它具有如此高的电影质量一样，我记得，我觉得那时我们真的陷入了这一集的基调中。
Like this is what we're making.
就像我们正在做的那样。
And then, you know, to get into like a little bit zip-zip-zip, although we can talk forever about drumroll.
然后，你知道，尽管我们可以永远谈论击鼓声，但还是有点像 zip-zip-zip。
But in that episode, we became a little bit more of a sitcom couple.
但在那一集中，我们更像是一对情景喜剧情侣。
We were like being held up to, we were celebrated and lionized in drumroll for our romanticism, and we were somewhat ridiculed in the next one, right?
我们就像被抓住了，我们因我们的浪漫主义而受到热烈的庆祝和崇拜，而我们在下一场比赛中却受到了一些嘲笑，对吗？
Yeah, because it was- I like to say public apology, do you look for that?
是的，因为那是——我喜欢公开道歉，你会寻找这样的道歉吗？
Well, no, it was because it was seen through Marshall and Lily's eyes.
嗯，不，那是因为这是通过马歇尔和莉莉的眼睛看到的。
that was part of the thing, was when you watch a couple in love, if you're a couple canoes down the river on your relationship, you're both jealous and disgusted all at the time of the couple.
这是事情的一部分，当你看到一对相爱的情侣时，如果你们是一对在你们的关系中顺流而下的情侣，你们在这对情侣的时候都会感到嫉妒和厌恶。
So we were the sacrificial lambs in that episode, and I think we had to crank it back to a little bit of a more of a sitcom style.
所以我们是那一集里的牺牲品，我想我们必须把它恢复到更像情景喜剧的风格。
But drum roll, and it's about even the end, So there's so much like soaring romanticism about it.
但鼓声响起，这甚至是结局，所以这很像高涨的浪漫主义。
I think it's a really, it's a great example of what How I Met Your Mother, I think, does best.
我认为这确实是《老爸老妈的浪漫史》的一个很好的例子，我认为它做得最好。
It's magic that episode.
那一集很神奇。
I mean, you guys in that episode, it is a romantic comedy.
我的意思是，那一集里的你们，这是一部浪漫喜剧。
It feels like a movie.
感觉就像电影一样。
It feels like a movie in 22 minutes.
感觉就像22分钟的电影。
And that's a really special one.
这是一个非常特别的。
That's some people's favorite episode of the entire series, like, including Pam Vryman.
这是整个系列中一些人最喜欢的一集，包括帕姆·弗里曼。
I think Pam would say that's way up there, if not the one for her.
我想帕姆会说，即使不适合她，那也是很不错的。
She called us into, I think your trailer after Drummeral Police had been edited together and she was like, I need both of you to come in, sit down and watch this.
她叫我们进去，我想你们在《鼓乐警察》之后的预告片已经一起编辑过了，她说，我需要你们俩进来，坐下来看这个。
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
That's a sweet.
那是一个甜蜜。
You remember that?
你还记得吗？
I do remember that, yeah.
我确实记得，是的。
Yeah, and I was like, I don't wanna watch myself, I'm gonna hate this.
是的，我当时想，我不想看着自己，我会讨厌这个。
And she was like, I don't care.
她说，我不在乎。
Like, I want you to just see this, you know, like just watch this and just get a, just understand the tone of what you guys did and what you created.
就像，我希望你们看到这个，你知道，就像只是观看这个，然后了解一下，了解你们所做的和创造的内容的基调。
Yeah, Pam had an incredible ability to make you feel like you were on the right track, like you were, it's such a, it's like what Ashley's describing on early experiences, like it's so uncomfortable to feel like I'm not getting this.
是的，帕姆有一种令人难以置信的能力，让你感觉自己走在正确的轨道上，就像阿什利描述的早期经历一样，感觉我不明白这一点是多么不舒服。
I'm not getting this, I'm not what they're looking for, I'm not, and Pam does the opposite.
我不明白，我不是他们要找的人，我不是，而帕姆却做了相反的事。
She makes you feel like you can't make a wrong turn.
她让你感觉你不会走错路。
And if you do, we're gonna redirect you, but with like this loving hand.
如果你这样做了，我们会用这只充满爱的手来引导你。
I think that's safety.
我认为这就是安全。
She's just a safety person.
她只是一个安全人员。
She makes you feel safe.
她让你感到安全。
She just creates conditions where you can do your best work and you feel the most free.
她只是创造条件，让你可以尽自己最大的努力，让你感到最自由。
And it's not like coddling and it's certainly not.
这不像溺爱，当然也不是。
She's not like telling you it's great when it's not great.
当事情不太好时，她不会告诉你这很好。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
She's really honest.
她真的很诚实。
But yeah, she just creates conditions.
但是，是的，她只是创造条件。
And then when, I mean, her thing of like wanting us to see it, I think was a little bit like, you should trust what you're doing here.
然后，我的意思是，当她希望我们看到它时，我认为有点像，你应该相信你在这里所做的事情。
Like trust us, trust Sue in the editing room, trust Crowder and Craig.
就像相信我们，相信编辑室里的苏，相信克劳德和克雷格。
Yeah, I think it's because of what you were saying about, good morning Miami, Ashley.
是的，我想这是因为你所说的，早安迈阿密，阿什利。
Like she was showing you this intimacy can work.
就像她向你展示的那样，这种亲密关系是可以发挥作用的。
This can be this small and sweet and real and be very funny and totally play.
这可以是这么小、这么甜蜜、这么真实，而且非常有趣、完全有趣。
So just be confident in that.
所以只要对此充满信心。
And I know what zip-sips up, we kind of then immediately undermined that after-term role, please, and made it the kind of like silly and ridiculous.
我知道会发生什么，然后我们立即破坏了这个期后的角色，拜托，让它变得愚蠢和荒谬。
It's sort of a silly, light, fun episode.
这是一个愚蠢、轻松、有趣的剧集。
It's very different until the drumroll certainly for you guys.
在鼓声响起之前，这对你们来说是非常不同的。
And it's kind of more of Marshall and the least perspective on the two of you on Ted and Victoria.
这更多的是马歇尔的观点，而对你们两个对泰德和维多利亚的看法最少。
But there would be more to come, like cupcake.
但还会有更多的东西出现，比如纸杯蛋糕。
There's a lot, cup that episode cupcake is about, it's that moment in a relationship where like, it's too soon to define this this much.
那一集纸杯蛋糕讲述了很多事情，这是一段关系中的那个时刻，现在定义这么多还为时过早。
But also I may leave in a few days for two years.
但几天后我也可能会离开两年。
So we have to.
所以我们必须这样做。
And that was like very human and real.
这非常人性化且真实。
And I think everybody has had a moment like that in some relationship in some way.
我认为每个人在某种关系中都以某种方式经历过这样的时刻。
And you guys played it very real and small.
你们玩得很真实而且很小。
And like, we got to see the sort of Ted side of that story and the victorious side of that story.
就像，我们看到了这个故事的泰德一面和胜利的一面。
And that's that, and again, it felt very filmic.
就是这样，再一次，感觉非常电影化。
It felt like Richard Linkletter before sunrise, like we all, Josh and I talk about all the time, how much we love those movies.
感觉就像日出前的理查德·林克莱特（Richard Linkletter），就像我们所有人，乔什和我一直在谈论我们有多么喜欢这些电影。
Like, did you, did you realize you were sort of safe to keep doing that?
就像，你有没有意识到继续这样做是安全的？
And then it worked once you saw Drumroll please?
当你看到 Drumroll 时，它就起作用了？
Like, did it take that moment Pam showing you that to feel like, oh yeah, this works on the show, I'm not gonna, you never seem like you were worried about getting fired by the way.
就像，帕姆在那一刻向你展示了这一点，让你感觉，哦，是的，这在节目中有效，我不会，你似乎从来没有担心过会被解雇。
you seemed very assured and calm.
你看起来非常自信和平静。
I never would have thought that, Ashley.
我从来没有想到过这一点，阿什利。
I never would have thought that.
我从来没想过会这样。
That might be the, that might be where the acting comes from.
这可能就是表演的来源。
You're not gonna hold up.
你不会坚持下去的。
I specifically remember in the audition, I made a joke and I made you guys laugh.
我特别记得在试镜的时候，我开了一个玩笑，让你们笑了。
Was I in your audition?
我参加过你的试镜吗？
Did I read with you?
我和你一起读书了吗？
Uh-uh.
呃呃。
Yeah, I didn't think I did.
是的，我不认为我做到了。
It was me and Pam and Carter, I think, I think, because we knew it was such an important role and we all wanted to be there, yeah.
我想是我、帕姆和卡特，因为我们知道这是一个如此重要的角色，我们都想在那里，是的。
It was a three of you.
那是你们三个人。
And by the way, I remember getting to the audition waiting room and there weren't that many people there.
顺便说一句，我记得去试镜候诊室时，那里人不多。
And I was like, and it was my first, it was the first budget, it wasn't a call back, it wasn't like a, didn't you, I don't even think it was a producer session.
我当时想，这是我的第一个，这是第一个预算，这不是回电，不像，不是吗，我什至不认为这是制片人会议。
It was just an audition.
这只是一次试镜。
But it felt intimate, like it felt special.
但感觉很亲密，感觉很特别。
There's sometimes you show up and there's literally a hundred people in front of you and you have to like send a text like, can someone let my dog out, you know?
有时你出现时，实际上有一百个人在你面前，你必须发一条短信，比如，有人可以把我的狗放出来吗，你知道吗？
I'm gonna be here all day.
我会在这里待一整天。
Yeah, this was a different, this felt special.
是的，这是一个不同的，这感觉很特别。
And I remember I was wearing, I had just gotten this like very cool shirt.
我记得我穿着我刚买的一件非常酷的衬衫。
It was like this like neat top and it was like sparkly.
就像这样，像整洁的上衣，又像闪闪发光。
It was whatever it was 2005.
无论如何，那是2005年的事情。
So I don't know how cool it actually was, but I was proud of it.
所以我不知道它到底有多酷，但我为此感到自豪。
And I came in and either you or Carter said, I like your shirt.
我进来时，你或卡特都说，我喜欢你的衬衫。
And I said.
我说。
They were saying hot top, bro.
他们说的是热顶，兄弟。
Hot top, bro.
热顶，兄弟。
Probably, probably.
大概，或许。
But you can't say that.
但你不能这么说。
You can't say that to an actress.
你不能对女演员说这种话。
No.
不。
Maybe you could have been 2005.
也许你本来可以是2005年。
I guess.
我猜。
But I said, thank you, it was really expensive.
但我说，谢谢你，它真的很贵。
And you guys started laughing and I was like, that's funny.
你们开始大笑，我想，这很有趣。
It was like a nibble.
就像是一口小口。
Like I was like, oh my god, they're picking up what I'm putting down.
就像我当时想的那样，天哪，他们正在捡起我放下的东西。
So much of the time you walk into an audition room and they're like, can you stop making jokes?
很多时候，当你走进试镜室时，他们会问，你能别再开玩笑了吗？
We're trying to make comedy stuff joking.
我们正在努力让喜剧变成笑话。
Yeah, exactly.
是的，完全正确。
But you guys laughed and I was like, oh, like they're here, they're with me.
但你们笑了，我就想，哦，就像他们在这里，他们和我在一起。
Yeah, yeah, and we were.
是的，是的，我们就是。
Yeah, and you were.
是的，你也是。
You know, that's a great observation.
你知道，这是一个很好的观察。
I had that feeling at my audition to like, these are human beings who are in the room with me.
我在试镜时就有这样的感觉，这些都是和我一起在房间里的人。
Like sometimes there is that glazed thing of like, oh, I can't do anything to puncture through whatever is the between me and this table.
就像有时会有那种光滑的东西，哦，我无法做任何事情来刺穿我和这张桌子之间的任何东西。
You know, like, but it's such a relief when you get in front of human beings who see you.
你知道，但是当你站在看到你的人们面前时，你会感到很轻松。
It's like those are the jobs you get generally or those are the jobs you get close on are like, yeah.
就像这些是你通常得到的工作，或者那些是你接近的工作，是的。
close it.
关闭它。
Yeah, but it but it was interesting because like I remember during this time and going back to like your your first initial question, I was deeply in the world of desperately trying to get a job when I booked how I met your mother and I had like and it went on I mean I shot 13 pilots in a row um as the lead.
是的，但这很有趣，因为就像我记得在这段时间里，回到你的第一个最初的问题，当我记录我如何遇见你母亲时，我深深地陷入了拼命寻找工作的世界，我喜欢这样，然后我的意思是我作为主角连续射击了 13 名飞行员。
I mean it just didn't say it was just every pilot season I was testing twice a week.
我的意思是它只是没有说这只是每个试点赛季我每周测试两次。
I was I was just right in there and never really it was able to cool on my way and do a secure job.
我当时就在那里，但它从来没有真正能够在我的路上冷却下来并安全地工作。
And so so much of what I was doing when I was on that set was like, oh my gosh, they did it.
当我在片场时，我所做的很多事情就像是，天哪，他们做到了。
And I remember like cornering you Josh and being like, did you test how many other test offers did you have?
我记得乔希把你逼到墙角，然后问你有没有测试过你还有多少其他测试机会？
And how did it go?
进展如何？
And is this scary?
这可怕吗？
And are you okay?
你还好吗？
And I remember it was so much about like, are we, are we going to be okay?
我记得当时很多人都在想，我们，我们会好吗？
Because you were also like, I don't know, like I don't think many people are watching this show.
因为你也说，我不知道，我认为没有多少人在看这个节目。
It kind It kind of feels like a little secret.
有点像一个小秘密的感觉。
Not many of them would have erred by the time you were there, right?
当你在那里的时候，他们中没有多少人会犯错误，对吗？
We were like, still this new show.
我们就像，仍然是这个新节目。
Who knew what was going to happen?
谁知道会发生什么？
Yeah.
是的。
Well, I was just going to say, I was on set the day that you guys got your back nine.
好吧，我只是想说，你们拿到后九洞的那天我就在片场。
Oh, wow.
哦，哇。
I didn't remember that.
我不记得了。
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, that's cool.
是的，那很酷。
I think you and Carter may have known previously, but the cast didn't know.
我想你和卡特之前可能已经知道了，但演员们不知道。
And I was there when you came in and made the announcement.
当你进来宣布这一消息时我就在场。
And it was like such a big deal, you know?
这就像一件大事，你知道吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, oh, that's so weird that you were part of that because you were such a huge part of those back nine episodes, like that was right.
是的，哦，这太奇怪了，你是其中的一部分，因为你是后九集的重要组成部分，就像那是对的。
I mean, that was, your entry point was right then.
我的意思是，那时你的切入点就是对的。
It's like, that's so cool.
就好像，这太酷了。
I'm so glad you're part of that.
我很高兴你参与其中。
It's also funny to think, Ashley, that you were turning to me as if I was some sort of resident expert on being on a show that lasted, like, it was my first, I had had everything that could have happened to me on a TV show, except it being a long running hit.
想想也很有趣，阿什利，你转向我，就好像我是某种持续演出的常驻专家，就像，这是我的第一次，我在电视节目中经历过一切可能发生在我身上的事情，除了它是一个长期热播的节目。
Like I got replaced on my first one.
就像我的第一个被替换一样。
The second one was canceled.
第二个被取消了。
We shot six, aired three, the third one didn't get picked up, and then I did how I met your mother, right?
我们拍了六部，播出了三部，第三部没拍到，然后我就按照我遇见你妈妈的方式做了，对吧？
So I was new to the game of, oh, the network wants to keep us on the air.
所以我对这个游戏还是个新手，哦，网络想让我们继续直播。
Like, that wasn't something I had had any experience with, but I was a part of this thing that just kept working, you know?
就像，这不是我有任何经验的事情，但我是这件事的一部分，一直在工作，你知道吗？
Well, maybe that was why it was so interesting to me, because you and I were in the same place.
好吧，也许这就是为什么它对我来说如此有趣，因为你和我在同一个地方。
I had done a couple of shows, a little bit, like the longer you've been at it, Like William Goldman, the screenwriter of, you know, Princess Bride and all these other great things, but he said, no one knows anything.
我做过几部剧，一点点，就像你参与的时间越长，就像威廉·戈德曼（William Goldman）一样，你知道，《公主新娘》和所有其他伟大作品的编剧，但他说，没有人知道任何事情。
Like famously, he said about Hollywood, like no one knows anything, no one knows why something works, why something doesn't work, something can have all the elements and not work.
正如他在谈到好莱坞时所说的那样，就像没有人知道任何事情一样，没有人知道为什么某些东西有效，为什么某些东西不起作用，某些东西可以拥有所有元素但不起作用。
Another thing comes out of nowhere, and it's just beloved and embraced and iconic.
另一件事情不知从何而来，它只是受人喜爱、被拥抱和标志性的。
And I think that we were both in the midst of, like, how do you make this work?
我认为我们都在思考，你如何让这项工作成功？
How do you get a thing going?
你如何让事情进行下去？
And you returning to us, like, Hey, you guys seem to have a thing going.
当你回到我们身边时，就像，嘿，你们似乎有事情发生。
How'd you do it?
你是怎么做到的？
And we were like, we have no idea.
我们就像，我们不知道。
We don't know.
我们不知道。
I did all those, you know, I did all those pilots with like the best of intentions.
我做了所有这些，你知道，我做所有这些飞行员​​都是出于最好的意图。
Like I was really trying hard.
就像我真的很努力一样。
I was doing my best.
我已经尽力了。
I was showing up, you know?
我出现了，你知道吗？
And this one just worked.
而这个刚刚奏效了。
So I have a question for you actually like, one of the interesting things I think about doing a long running show is the writers are figuring out who you are as you go.
所以我有一个问题想问你，我认为制作一部长期演出的有趣的事情之一是编剧们正在弄清楚你是谁。
And they're also, we've talked a little bit about this, like you have an idea, like for instance, Marshall was not written to be six foot four, but then Jason Siegel gets cast and his height becomes a vein of comedy they can mine.
我们也对此进行了一些讨论，就像你有一个想法一样，例如，马歇尔的身高不是六英尺四英寸，但后来杰森·西格尔被选为演员，他的身高成为他们可以挖掘的喜剧脉络。
He was written to be seven feet tall, but Jason was a little shorter than that.
他被写为七英尺高，但杰森比这个矮一点。
Right, but you came on and they had this idea for this character and then you're obviously, you're affecting the writing as they go.
是的，但是你来了，他们对这个角色有了这个想法，然后你显然，你正在影响他们的写作。
They're tailoring this suit to you, but also you as an actor are opening up that new draft for the next episode and you're like, oh, Victoria, she applied for a baking fellowship and you're like, you're learning new things about who this person is.
他们正在为你量身定制这套衣服，但你作为演员正在为下一集打开新的草稿，你就像，哦，维多利亚，她申请了烘焙奖学金，你就像，你正在学习关于这个人是谁的新知识。
Was that, do you remember that as like a thing of like kind of discovering it as you go?
那是吗，你还记得那是一种边走边发现的事情吗？
Well, that's one of my favorite things about TV is, you know, what I always felt like, I always feel like when I come into audition for a TV show, I'm going, all right, if you choose the Ashley Williams path, here's the path that you're gonna get, you know?
嗯，这是我对电视最喜欢的事情之一，你知道，我一直觉得，当我参加电视节目试镜时，我总是觉得，我会，好吧，如果你选择阿什利·威廉姆斯的道路，这就是你会走的路，你知道吗？
like here's the little pockets that you can go into.
就像这是你可以放进去的小口袋。
And, you know, like I remember I read in the script that I was tap dancing and my husband's incredible tap dancer.
而且，你知道，就像我记得我在剧本中读到的那样，我是踢踏舞，也是我丈夫令人难以置信的踢踏舞者。
Nowhere.
无处。
So yeah, so I.
所以是的，所以我。
You're making this up.
这是你编造的。
Neil's on camera right now.
尼尔现在在镜头前。
Can he come?
他能来吗？
Can you get me?
你能得到我吗？
That's unbelievable.
这太难以置信了。
He comes on camera right now.
他现在出现在镜头前。
Wait, what are you saying?
等等，你在说什么？
Oh, you're really doing it.
哦，你真的很会做。
I didn't, that was a joke, that was a joke.
我没有，那是个玩笑，那是个玩笑。
Neil's gonna hate me.
尼尔会恨我的。
Don't tell him it was my idea.
别告诉他这是我的主意。
Look at him.
看看他。
I feel like you're doing it.
我感觉你正在做这件事。
I feel like you might be in a meeting.
我感觉你可能正在开会。
I feel like I'm not doing a meeting.
我感觉我不是在开会。
But he was really good at tap dancing.
但他踢踏舞确实很擅长。
And I had to do the two time step.
我必须执行两次步骤。
What's it called?
它叫什么？
Whatever it's called where you, blah, blah, blah.
无论你在哪里叫什么，等等，等等。
And I said to Neil, you have to teach me how to do this.
我对尼尔说，你必须教我如何做到这一点。
And we were in this tiny apartment in Santa Monica.
我们住在圣莫尼卡的一间小公寓里。
And he's trying to freaking teach me how to do this.
他正试图教我如何做到这一点。
And I cannot get it, right?
而且我无法得到它，对吧？
I mean we he was trying to teach me for like an hour, you know over and over and over again And finally he was like you're gonna have to lean into the fact that you're terrible at this.
我的意思是，我们他试图教我大约一个小时，你知道一遍又一遍，最后他就像你必须接受这样一个事实：你在这方面很糟糕。
Yeah Oh my god, this is my husband Neil Neil do you remember when you I had to tap dance on the episode of how I met your mother and you had to teach me had a tap dance and you were like, you can't do it.
是的哦天哪，这是我的丈夫尼尔尼尔，你还记得当你在我如何遇见你母亲的那一集中不得不跳踢踏舞时，你必须教我跳踢踏舞，而你却说，你做不到。
Yes, there's not enough.
是的，还不够。
Can you show them how to do it?
你能告诉他们怎么做吗？
Oh, no, no, no.
哦，不，不，不。
I feel like you put a tap dance in right now.
我感觉你现在加入了踢踏舞。
We should make it in this app.
我们应该在这个应用程序中实现它。
No, no.
不，不。
Absolutely.
绝对地。
But it is very good to see you.
但很高兴见到你。
It's an amazing tap dancer.
这是一位了不起的踢踏舞者。
Like, he's incredible.
就像，他太不可思议了。
Neil, I would have had the exact same response by him.
尼尔，我也会得到他完全相同的回应。
No, that's why I felt comfortable saying it, just there's no chance in a pill that you would have tap danced on a podcast with your wife.
不，这就是为什么我觉得这么说很舒服，只是在药丸中你不可能和你的妻子在播客上跳踢踏舞。
You would buy it from her.
你会从她那里买的。
She's not fucking with us, right?
她没有和我们开玩笑吧？
It actually, you actually are good.
其实，你其实很好。
I am actually really good, but I would never in a million years do it anywhere except for when she needed my help.
我实际上真的很好，但一百万年内我永远不会在任何地方这样做，除非她需要我的帮助。
Yeah, very, how'd you learn how to tap dance, Neil?
是的，非常，你是怎么学会踢踏舞的，尼尔？
Crazy for you?
为你疯狂吗？
Oh, sure.
哦，当然。
Harry Grainer was on our show.
哈利·格兰纳出现在我们的节目中。
Oh yeah, he was the star.
哦，是的，他是明星。
That's the part I played.
这就是我扮演的角色。
In high school.
在高中时。
I was like tap dancing my face off in high school.
我就像高中时的踢踏舞一样。
This is crazy.
这太疯狂了。
But when you were trying to teach me how to tap dance and you said you're gonna just have to lean into the comedy here because you're terrible at this.
但是当你试图教我如何跳踢踏舞时，你说你只能靠这里的喜剧，因为你在这方面很糟糕。
This is not gonna look like, you know, this is happening.
这看起来不会像，你知道，这正在发生。
So then I came and I came and I said, I have to put in, like, I don't really know how to have dance.
然后我来了，我来了，我说，我必须投入，就像，我真的不知道如何跳舞。
And that was so funny.
那太有趣了。
Yeah, so that was.
是的，就是这样。
Say it everybody.
大家说一下吧。
Had this old man.
有这个老头。
He musted me, fell in love with you.
他必须我，爱上你。
New York City.
纽约市。
And now, commercials.
现在，广告。
Hey, I'm Carl Radke.
嘿，我是卡尔·拉德克。
You might know me from Bravo's Summer House, but on my podcast More Life, I get your favorite reality stars off the clock and into the conversations you don't usually get to hear.
您可能是在 Bravo's Summer House 认识我的，但在我的播客 More Life 中，我会不分昼夜地邀请您最喜欢的真人秀明星进行您通常听不到的对话。
The deep stuff.
深奥的东西。
The vulnerable stuff.
脆弱的东西。
The uncomfortable stuff.
那些不舒服的东西。
I've sat down with Sierra Miller, Derinda Medley, Tom Schwartz, Lindsey Hubbard, and a whole lot more.
我与塞拉·米勒 (Sierra Miller)、德林达·梅德利 (Derinda Medley)、汤姆·施瓦茨 (Tom Schwartz)、林赛·哈伯德 (Lindsey Hubbard) 等人进行了交谈。
We get into relationships, growing up, the messy stuff, and everything that happens when the cameras aren't rolling.
我们会陷入人际关系、成长、混乱的事情，以及摄像机不转动时发生的一切。
New episodes of More Life every week, listen wherever you get your podcasts, or watch on YouTube.
每周都有新剧集《更多生活》，无论您在哪里有播客，都可以收听，或者在 YouTube 上观看。
of commercials, back to Shell.
广告，回到壳牌。
Josh, do you remember when Neil had to, do you remember what, do you know what I'm going to say?
乔希，你还记得尼尔什么时候必须这么做吗？你还记得什么吗？你知道我要说什么吗？
No.
不。
Okay.
好的。
So you sat me down one time, you said Ashley, you said every time you kissed me.
所以你有一次让我坐下来，你说阿什利，你每次吻我的时候都这么说。
Oh, oh shit.
哦，哦，该死。
I do know what you're going to say.
我知道你要说什么。
Go ahead.
前进。
This is amazing.
这太棒了。
Go ahead.
前进。
Here it goes.
就这样吧。
Every time you kissed me.
每次你吻我的时候。
Now Neil and I had, Neil and I had been together for 22 years.
现在尼尔和我在一起了，尼尔和我已经在一起 22 年了。
So we had only been together for like a, maybe a year or so, uh, when I was, when I got how I met your mother and I was absolutely obsessed and infatuated, still am, um, but when every time Josh and I had a kiss on the show, I was very careful to have like boundaries, right?
所以我们只在一起了大约一年左右，呃，当我知道我是如何认识你母亲的时候，我绝对着迷和迷恋，现在仍然是，嗯，但是当每次乔什和我在节目中接吻时，我都非常小心地保持界限，对吗？
So I remember being like, like, every time we kissed her, we'd go like, oh, like, I had the car.
所以我记得每次我们亲吻她时，我们都会说，哦，就像，我有车。
The only way I can describe it possibly is like hard lips, hard lips, hard lips, hard lips all ahead.
我唯一能描述它的方式就是像坚硬的嘴唇，坚硬的嘴唇，坚硬的嘴唇，坚硬的嘴唇。
So one time Josh was like, hey, can I talk to you about something?
有一次，乔什说，嘿，我可以和你谈谈一件事吗？
And I was like, yeah, anything.
我当时想，是的，什么都可以。
He was like, you kind of like are like pushing me away with your mouth every time he came.
他说，每次他来的时候，你就像是用你的嘴把我推开。
I was like, are you serious?
我当时想，你是认真的吗？
Oh no.
哦不。
And then I brought, I sat down with Neil to watch an episode.
然后我带来了，我和尼尔一起坐下来看了一集。
And Neil was like, this is a big problem.
尼尔说，这是一个大问题。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
Like he saw it?
就像他看到的那样？
Yeah, he totally saw it.
是的，他完全看到了。
And he was like, you have to stop.
他说，你必须停下来。
And then he sat with me on the couch.
然后他和我一起坐在沙发上。
And he was like, pretend I'm Josh.
他说，假装我是乔什。
I remember this.
我记得这个。
Oh my God, this is getting so weird right now guys.
天哪，伙计们，现在这变得太奇怪了。
This is getting so weird.
这变得太奇怪了。
And he was like, now let me pretend you're Josh.
他说，现在让我假装你是乔什。
Wait, so yes, I 100% remember this now, but what I was saying was, and it was very delicate what I was trying to do, which was to say, how did you say this?
等等，是的，我现在百分百记得这一点，但我所说的是，而且我想做的事情非常微妙，也就是说，你是怎么说的？
I think I what I was saying was like, you're kissing me weird, right?
我想我刚才说的是，你吻我的方式很奇怪，对吧？
I think that's all I was saying was like, you're kissing me weird.
我想这就是我所说的，你吻我的方式很奇怪。
And I'm participating in this, and I would love to create a safe space where you could relax.
我正在参与其中，我很乐意创造一个可以让您放松的安全空间。
So I think what I I you know, I had such a weird job I had to be like though.
所以我想我知道，我的工作很奇怪，但我不得不这样做。
I had to welcome Actresses for nine years that I would like either kiss or romance and I had to I had to be like a safe space for them Like I wasn't can you just be on the record like I was not a creepy?
九年来，我必须欢迎女演员，我想要亲吻或浪漫，我必须为她们提供一个安全的空间，就像我不是一样，你能像我不是一个令人毛骨悚然的人一样记录在案吗？
And I became very good friends with Neil over the years document.
这些年来我和尼尔成了很好的朋友。
Yeah, so I had to be I had to love each other Yeah, I had to thread a very particular needle, which was I'm not trying to get you to like shove your throat or anything But I would like you to feel free to relax into like a kiss that will feel like an actual People are gonna think drumroll please came out of this and I just want to clarify I did not drumroll Jesus its own concept because the whole episode was about not quite kissing it was not part of this This is a totally what if one of the DVD extras was victorious saying well Why don't you want kiss and Victoria says I my lips go hard I'm not good at it No, I do remember you telling me that you had a practice session with Neil Yeah, that is like my god.
是的，所以我必须是，我必须彼此相爱是的，我必须穿一根非常特别的针，这就是我不想让你喜欢推你的喉咙或任何东西，但我希望你能自由地放松，就像一个吻，感觉就像一个真实的人们会认为击鼓请从这个中出来，我只是想澄清我没有击鼓耶稣自己的概念，因为整集是关于不完全接吻它不是这的一部分这完全是如果DVD之一临时演员胜利了，说好，你为什么不想接吻，维多利亚说我的嘴唇用力，我不擅长，不，我记得你告诉我你和尼尔一起练习了是的，这就像我的上帝。
My wife.
我的妻子。
She can't have dance or kiss What can she do and Neil is famously good in kissing which we all By the way, great kisser Yeah, but no I do I do want to commend you Josh for handling that is so professionally and you did, you always created an incredibly safe space.
她不能跳舞或接吻她能做什么，尼尔在接吻方面是出了名的好，我们大家都知道，顺便说一句，伟大的接吻者是的，但不，我确实想赞扬你乔什处理得如此专业，你做到了，你总是创造了一个令人难以置信的安全空间。
And I think I just was, no, I was nervous, you know, I was just nervous about being intimate.
我想我只是，不，我很紧张，你知道，我只是对亲密感到紧张。
I never noticed this for one second, just to say that I never noticed this.
我一秒钟都没有注意到这一点，只是说我从来没有注意到这一点。
I sat in that room looking at these pigs for a lot, a lot of episodes that had caught her.
我坐在那个房间里看着这些猪很多很多，很多吸引她的情节。
Never once did we talk, this is completely news to me.
我们从来没有说过话，这对我来说完全是新闻。
I mean, it's literally, it was enough for me to literally sit her down and say, can we talk about this?
我的意思是，从字面上看，这足以让我坐下来问她，我们可以谈谈这个吗？
I'm sure that I was nervous to say something, although I'm sure it's hard to be nervous around you.
我确信我在说某些话时很紧张，尽管我确信在你身边很难感到紧张。
You're so open and welcoming.
你是如此开放和热情。
And you know, I mean, look, over the years, like, cause I remember years later, you were giving me some like very strong advice on a relationship.
你知道，我的意思是，多年来，因为我记得多年后，你给了我一些关于人际关系的非常强烈的建议。
I was in, we don't have to go into it, but there was someone I was dating who you kind of knew.
我参与了，我们不必深究，但我正在和一个你认识的人约会。
And like, I remember, I always, I will say this, when you, when there was a Victoria episode, I was always delighted to see you.
就像，我记得，我总是，我会这么说，当你，当有维多利亚插曲时，我总是很高兴见到你。
Like truly delighted.
就像真正高兴一样。
I found the set so fun when you were there.
当你在场的时候，我发现这个场景非常有趣。
And just to kind of like, you know, we would have our stories together, right, generally, except in cupcake when you were with the girls.
就像，你知道，我们会一起讲故事，对吧，一般来说，除了当你和女孩们在一起的时候在纸杯蛋糕上。
But like, it was always so great when nothing was going on, just to like crash on the couch and just like, sit around and catch up.
但是，当什么事都没有发生时，就像坐在沙发上一样，坐在一起聊聊天，这总是很棒的。
And we would chat like it was but like we would go deep.
我们会像以前一样聊天，但就像我们会深入讨论一样。
We would go deep Roll fast like it is immediately into like and why is that your greatest fear like You know like an egg burrito that does sound like zip zip zip maybe there was some truth to it But I think also we were we both came from theater schools and theater schools They train you like go go deep quick, you know like you've got a you know It's what they call instamacy, right?
我们会深入滚动，就像它立即进入喜欢一样，为什么你最大的恐惧就像你知道就像一个鸡蛋卷饼，听起来确实像拉链拉链拉链也许有一些真相但我想我们也来自戏剧学校和戏剧学校他们训练你快速深入，你知道就像你有一个你知道的，这就是他们所谓的instamacy，对吗？
Like you've got to really throw yourself in.
就像你必须真正全身心投入一样。
And we were approximating like a really deep, quick relationship.
我们之间的关系已经非常深入、迅速。
And I felt like as actors, we had like a real deep, quick, easy chemistry with each other.
我觉得作为演员，我们彼此之间有着真正深刻、快速、轻松的化学反应。
I always felt that.
我一直这么觉得。
I agreed.
我同意了。
Yeah.
是的。
I always felt really at home with you and really, like it felt cozy.
和你在一起我总是感到宾至如归，真的很舒服。
It always just felt very safe and very cozy.
总是感觉非常安全和舒适。
It's not easy, Ashley, to come in and do what you did, which is come into this kind of cake that had baked itself so much.
阿什利，进来做你所做的事情并不容易，这就是进入这种已经烤了很多次的蛋糕。
I'm going with a baking metaphor and not even on purpose, but it's so fucking works.
我用烘焙来比喻，甚至不是故意的，但它真的太管用了。
And it's hard to jump in and just be like, and now I'm the new kid in this kind of, it's like you came into the college semester halfway through the semester kind of, and immediately to your credit felt like you belonged.
很难跳进去，就像，现在我是这种新来的孩子，就像你在学期中途进入大学学期一样，立刻就觉得你有归属感。
I said in another episode, and I want to make sure I say it while you're actually here, I wish it had been a 24 episode season, so we could have added two more Victoria episodes.
我在另一集中说过，我想确保我是在你真正在这里的时候说的，我希望这是一个 24 集的季节，所以我们可以再添加两集维多利亚。
I feel like it was a bridge, we were a 22 episode season and later seasons were 24.
我觉得这是一座桥梁，我们的一季有 22 集，后来的几季有 24 集。
If we had had two more, we would have had two more fun episodes with you that rather than like the arc we'd sort of booked you for and written and planned out.
如果我们再有两集，我们就会和你一起看两集更有趣的剧集，而不是像我们为你预订、编写和计划的弧线那样。
But did you like, was that hard?
但你喜欢吗，这很难吗？
Was that hard to kind of parachute in and try to feel like part of the team?
跳伞并尝试融入团队是不是很困难？
Cause it seemed from the outside, like you were immediately in and felt like part of the team.
因为从外面看，你就像是立即融入团队并感觉自己是团队的一部分。
That is first of all, such a nice compliment.
首先，这是一个很好的赞美。
It was entirely because, and I say this as a person now, And not this was not true at the time, but now I've been a guest star like 200 times.
这完全是因为，我现在作为一个人这么说，当时并不是这样，但现在我已经客串了大约 200 次。
Like I've literally done 200 guest art episodes where I come in for just a couple, little recurings, little, you know, a one off of whatever.
就像我实际上已经完成了 200 集客座艺术剧集一样，其中我只参加了几集，一点点重复，一点点，你知道，无论什么都是一次性的。
Like that's been my career, you know?
这就是我的职业生涯，你知道吗？
So I am now, so I find it so second nature to show up on a set and immediately start learning people's names and listen very intently to like the culture and the subtext and kind of, you smell it before you see it.
现在我就是这样，所以我发现出现在片场并立即开始学习人们的名字并非常专心地聆听喜欢文化和潜台词以及某种程度的第二天性，你在看到它之前就闻到了它。
You know what I mean, like it's really like figuring it.
你知道我的意思，就像它真的就像在计算它一样。
It's really every, yeah, every set is completely different.
确实，每一组都是完全不同的。
And learning each set's culture is something that has really, I mean, it's taken a long time for me to really get good at.
我的意思是，学习每个系列的文化确实需要很长时间才能真正擅长。
And now interestingly enough, I'm now an episodic director and it's what I think is one of my assets as an episodic director is I can come on and immediately go, ooh, okay, so he said that guy's in charge.
有趣的是，我现在是一名剧集导演，我认为作为一名剧集导演，我的资产之一就是我可以上场并立即离开，哦，好吧，所以他说那个人负责。
We're scared of her, you know, and just immediately start picking up on all the cues.
你知道，我们很害怕她，所以我们立即开始捕捉所有的线索。
But I have to say, your set was really different than that because immediately, I mean, I remember my first day, so after Pam took us all the breakfast, then Ali took me through and gave me a tour of the entire stage.
但我不得不说，你的布景真的很不一样，因为我立刻就记得我的第一天，所以在帕姆带我们吃完早餐后，阿里带我参观了整个舞台。
She was like, here's where all your dressing rooms, here's the dressing rooms, here's her makeup, here are all the different sets, and she showed me where the bathrooms were, where the turkey bacon was.
她说，这是所有更衣室的地方，这是更衣室，这是她的化妆品，这是所有不同的布景，她向我展示了浴室在哪里，火鸡培根在哪里。
It was the very, she immediately made me feel so at home, and it was a priority of the whole cast to do that, and that is not normally the case.
她立即​​让我感到宾至如归，这是整个演员的首要任务，但通常情况并非如此。
Normally, I guess, it feels like a threat to the cast, And I was not made to feel like that at all.
通常情况下，我想，这感觉像是对演员的威胁，而我根本没有被要求有这样的感觉。
It's so true what you're saying.
你说的太对了
I haven't guest-starred that much, but when I have, it's incredibly, it's like, it's beyond first day of school vibes.
我客串过的次数不多，但当我客串过的时候，这真是令人难以置信，就像，这超出了开学第一天的氛围。
Like it is, you are, because not, it's not everyone's first day of school.
就像它是，你是，因为不是，这不是每个人上学的第一天。
It's just your first day of school.
这只是你上学的第一天。
So you're entering this ecosystem that really does have its own bylaws and its own language.
所以你正在进入这个生态系统，它确实有自己的章程和自己的语言。
And it's like, you're a tourist.
就像，你是一名游客。
So I commend you for doing that 200 times.
所以我赞扬你这样做了 200 次。
Like, it's really a big thing.
比如说，这确实是一件大事。
I don't love doing it, to be honest.
老实说，我不喜欢这样做。
I like having the thing where it's like, you come to my home, I don't like to come to yours, you know.
我喜欢这样的事情，你来我家，我不喜欢来你家，你知道。
I don't know.
我不知道。
I think it's fun, you know.
我觉得这很有趣，你知道。
But I also, you know, I really love, like I really love what we do.
但我也，你知道，我真的很喜欢，就像我真的很喜欢我们所做的那样。
I think it is the most fun.
我认为这是最好玩的。
So coming in and cracking how each set tells their story is just some of the most fun in the world, because it, but it all is the same.
因此，进入并破解每个场景如何讲述他们的故事只是世界上最有趣的事情之一，因为它，但一切都是一样的。
And you know, I will, I will say this actually, this is just occurring to me, but this feels very true to me is that, you know, I was working, especially in the first season, I was, I was nervous.
你知道，我会，我实际上会这么说，这只是发生在我身上，但这对我来说非常真实，你知道，我在工作，特别是在第一季，我很紧张。
I was, you know, I'm a good student, like I wanted to do well, right?
我是，你知道，我是一个好学生，就像我想做得很好，对吧？
But it's also like the role and acting generally requires a certain amount of looseness and risk and fit, you know, acceptance of failure and like it's all going to be.
但这也就像角色和表演通常需要一定程度的放松、风险和配合，你知道，接受失败，就像一切都会这样。
And you, what I think you bring to a set, and this is why I think you've been so employable, is that I got the feeling like whenever you were on set, there's a little bit of a feeling underneath everything you do, which is like, can you believe we're getting away with this and that they're paying us to do this?
而你，我认为你给片场带来的，这就是为什么我认为你如此受雇的原因，是我有一种感觉，就像每当你在片场时，你所做的一切背后都有一种感觉，就像是，你能相信我们能逃脱惩罚吗？他们付钱给我们来做这件事？
Like there's a feeling of like, like this is insane that this is our career.
就像有一种感觉，就像这是我们的职业，这太疯狂了。
Like this thing we just like doing as kids, we now get to do as adults.
就像我们小时候喜欢做的事情一样，现在我们成年人也可以做。
And that's the best it should feel that way.
这就是最好的感觉。
And it reminded me that like, as this guy I know who passed away, but this guy, Evio Tar-Frankle, who his kind of catchphrase was it's supposed to be fun.
这让我想起，就像我认识的这个人去世了一样，但是这个人，埃维奥·塔尔-弗兰克尔，他的口头禅是这应该很有趣。
Remember it's supposed to be fun.
请记住，这应该很有趣。
And I feel like whenever you were on set, it was a reminder to me like it's supposed to be fun.
我觉得无论何时你在片场，都会提醒我这应该很有趣。
Yeah.
是的。
Oh, that's so cool.
哦，那太酷了。
I love that.
我喜欢那个。
Well, I remember when I first, one of my first days with Pam, I was like, tell me, because again, like coming from the intense multi-cam world, I was like, tell me about these show runners.
嗯，我记得当我第一次，和帕姆在一起的第一天，我想，告诉我，因为，就像来自激烈的多镜头世界一样，我想，告诉我关于这些节目主持人的事情。
Like, are they safe?
比如，他们安全吗？
Like, are they nice?
比如，他们好吗？
What's going on with them?
他们怎么了？
They were talking about my shirt and casting.
他们正在谈论我的衬衫和选角。
Do I have something to be worried about?
我有什么需要担心的吗？
Yeah, well, I was, I was just like, what do I have to be aware of?
是的，好吧，我是，我只是想，我必须注意什么？
And Pam said, they just can't believe there's craft service.
帕姆说，他们简直不敢相信还有工艺品服务。
And that was such a great line about you guys.
这对你们来说真是太好了。
They really set the tone, I think, for everybody.
我认为他们确实为每个人定下了基调。
But yeah, I agree, Josh, like getting any acting job, I feel like I'm like, I cannot believe we put this off.
但是，是的，我同意，乔什，就像得到任何表演工作一样，我觉得我不敢相信我们推迟了这件事。
Like how long before they come in and say, get the heck out of here, you crazy person.
就像过了多久他们就会进来并说，滚出去，你这个疯子。
Who do you think you are?
你以为你是谁？
But every day we get away with another day on set.
但每天我们都会在片场多度过一天。
I'm like, I can't believe they're not coming in and yelling at us and saying that we're ahead of our skis.
我想，我不敢相信他们没有进来对我们大喊大叫，说我们领先于我们的滑雪板。
God, that is the best description of what it means to stay curious and creative.
天啊，这就是对保持好奇心和创造力的最好描述。
That is what it is.
就是这样。
How do we get to do this?
我们怎样才能做到这一点？
How are we this lucky?
我们怎么这么幸运？
And at its best, that's what art feels like.
在最好的情况下，这就是艺术的感觉。
And you really do kind of exude that Like even like when you come and you sing with us, actually comes and she sings for these, the fundraiser that's really important to my, to my world and my family, it's sort of for my son.
你确实散发出一种感觉，甚至就像当你来和我们一起唱歌时，她真的来了，她为这些筹款活动唱歌，这对我、我的世界和我的家庭来说非常重要，这有点像是为了我的儿子。
And she comes and sings and performs.
她来唱歌、表演。
And it just feels that way, just you getting up and sing a song with us.
就是这样的感觉，只要你站起来和我们一起唱一首歌。
It feels that way.
感觉就是这样。
Like it's, I love that.
就像它一样，我喜欢这样。
I love that.
我喜欢那个。
That's so precious.
那真是太珍贵了。
When you first said, you know, Bowery Ballroom, what was it years ago?
当你第一次说，你知道，鲍厄里宴会厅，几年前是什么？
I was like, I am not a singer, Craig.
我当时想，我不是歌手，克雷格。
Like I don't.
就像我不一样。
Or a tough dancer.
或者是一个坚强的舞者。
Or much of a kisser.
或者说是一个接吻者。
But I'm not going to turn down the opportunity as a quintessentially non-singer.
但作为一个典型的非歌手，我不会拒绝这个机会。
People say, Oh, do you sing?
人们说，哦，你唱歌吗？
And I say, I sing enthusiastically, but not well, and so I'm getting to get up on stage at the Bellery Ballroom and being as untalented as a singer as I am.
我说，我唱歌很热情，但唱得不好，所以我要登上贝勒里舞厅的舞台，像我一样没有歌手的天赋。
It's just too funny to me.
这对我来说太有趣了。
It's too funny.
太搞笑了。
You were a living yes and.
你是一个活生生的人。
You were a living breathing yes and.
你是一个活生生的呼吸者，是的，而且。
Aw, thanks.
噢，谢谢。
Hey everyone, we had so much great Ashley Williams that we've actually made this one a two-parter.
大家好，我们有很多很棒的阿什利·威廉姆斯，所以我们实际上把这部剧做成了两部剧。
So come on back in about three days to hear part two of how we met Ashley Williams.
所以大约三天后回来听听我们如何认识阿什利·威廉姆斯的第二部分。
Let's roll the credits.
让我们滚动制作人员名单。
I am guilty.
我有罪。
Please equip me.
请装备我。
All sins are forgiven.
所有的罪孽都被宽恕了。
I knew you were sitting.
我知道你坐着。
How We Made Your Mother Is Hosted and Executive Produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《我们如何创造了你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并监制。
The show was produced by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
该节目由我 Alec Lev 制作，我们的联合制作人是 Doug Matica。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios, and our digital content producer, aka Gen Z Master, is Emily Blumber.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point of Blue Studios 的 Alex Reeves，我们的数字内容制作人（又名 Gen Z Master）是 Emily Blumber。
Artwork by John Morrow.
约翰·莫罗的艺术作品。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
really does help the show.
确实对节目有帮助。
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Radner 创作的《NYC》，其他音乐由 Craig Thomas 和 Andrew Majuski 创作。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢洛拉·肯尼迪和埃利奥特·康纳斯。
Visit HowWeMajorMother.com to sign up for our sub-stack mailing list and for links to our social media.
请访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 注册我们的子堆栈邮件列表以及我们社交媒体的链接。
You can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
您还可以单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Want some merch?
想要一些商品吗？
Click on the store link or go to HowYouGetYourMerch.com.
单击商店链接或访问 HowYouGetYourMerch.com。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's Muse Letters on Substack, order Craig Thomas' debut novel at CraigThomasRider.com slash novel, and you could subscribe to my Dead Father's Society, also on Substack.
在 Substack 上订阅乔什·拉德纳 (Josh Radner) 的《Muse Letters》，在 CraigThomasRider.com 斜杠小说上订购克雷格·托马斯 (Craig Thomas) 的处女作，你还可以在 Substack 上订阅我的《死去父亲的协会》(Dead Father's Society)。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for congenital heart disease research.
要了解您如何做出改变，这显示了正在进行的为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的活动。
Check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
查看我们网站顶部的“Make a Difference”选项卡。
This episode was made possible by the support of Backyard Ventures.
这一集是在 Backyard Ventures 的支持下才得以实现的。
will, in fact, dance.
事实上，会跳舞。